On January 3rd the United States
launched a drone strike near the Baghdad
International Airport in Iraq it killed
several Iraqi and Iranian military
officials including Iran's top commander
named Qasem Soleimani moments later
Iran's supreme leader declared soleimani
a martyr and threatened severe revenge
against the US over the next few days
hundreds of thousands of Iranians came
out to mourn somebody's death
but Iran wasn't the only place where
people took to the streets there are
demonstrations in Iraq Syria Lebanon and
Yemen these are some of the countries
where sulemani commanded a network of
powerful militias which gave him and
Iran extraordinary influence across the
region this network made him one of the
most important people in Iran it's also
what got him killed so how did sulemani
expand Iran's influence and what happens
to these militias after his death
[Music]
it all began with Iran's Islamic
Revolution in 1979 a cleric named
Ayatollah Khomeini led a popular
movement that toppled Iran's monarch and
established the Islamic Republic of Iran
this new regime wanted to export their
revolution and that threatened countries
all over the Middle East Iran was also
the first Shia government that billed
itself as the preeminent leader of the
Muslim world that especially threatened
Iran Sunni dominated neighbors the first
one to act was Iraq in 1980 dictator
Saddam Hussein sent his army to invade
around
other countries that felt threatened by
Iran supported him the u.s. sent some
weapons to Iran but mainly supported
Iraq throughout the war hoping to keep
Iran's ambitions in check the war
carried on for eight years and nearly a
million died during that time Iran was
devastated and surrounded by enemies so
it devised a strategy to spread its
ideology and fight its enemies covertly
at the same time but a first needed a
security force to find groups to partner
with outside of Iran's borders so in the
80s it put together an elite unit of
soldiers and spies called the Kurds
force they became part of Iran's Islamic
Revolutionary Guard Corps a branch of
the military that answered directly to
Iran's supreme leader next it needed an
opportunity to unleash this force and it
found one in Lebanon in the 1970s a
civil war was raging in Lebanon the US
had sent troops as peacekeepers but
violence was spilling over into Israel
so in 1982 Israel invaded Lebanon
several Lebanese militias fought back
some of these militias were led by Shia
clerics who had ideological ties to Iran
so Iran sent forces millions of dollars
and tons of weapons to back their fight
they eventually merged into one powerful
Shia militia called Hezbollah
the attacked Israeli soldiers in Lebanon
and launched Rockets over the border
into Israel Hezbollah even bombed the US
Embassy and barracks
killing 304 people eventually Hezbollah
succeeded the US troops left Lebanon in
1984 and Israel pulled out in 2000
Aaron's dual strategy had worked it
turned Hezbollah into a reliable proxy
that could fight Israel and even the US
on its behalf without inciting conflict
on its own borders Iran had also found
an effective way to export its ideology
to Lebanon so Iran's cuts for started
supporting proxy militias in Palestine
and Iraq as it built the foundation for
a network a charismatic soldier worked
his way up the ranks in 1998 custom
Soleimani took command of the cuts force
and within a few years he had an
opportunity to firmly establish Iran's
influence in Iraq in 2003 the u.s.
invaded and toppled Saddam Hussein and
his Sunni dominated regime this created
a power vacuum in Iraq which was quickly
filled by Shias
sulemani used this opportunity to
continue to back Shia militias here
growing his network into a powerful
force that fought against the US and
other Iraqis
it turned into one of the most violent
periods in rocks troubled history
thousands of civilians died many at the
hands of Soleimani Zaraki malicious but
eventually a Shia dominated government
took control of Iraq soleimani had
managed to solidify Iran's influence in
Iraq when another opportunity arose this
time in Syria in 2011 protests in Syria
turned into a civil war which threatened
to overthrow dictator Bashar al-assad
so money orchestrated his network of
proxies to work together to defend Assad
he called in Hezbollah fighters from
Lebanon Shia militias from Iraq and even
soldiers from Iran he also created two
new militias with Afghan and Pakistani
fighters all these groups fought
alongside the Syrian army to keep Assad
in power this intensified a war that
eventually killed more than 500,000
people mostly civilians and displaced
more than 11 million but Assad survived
sulemani was successfully exploiting
conflicts to advance Iran's interests
across the region and was making him a
very popular figure in Iran he became
arguably the second most important
person in the country more conflicts
gave Iran more opportunities when Isis
sparked another war in Iraq
sulemani again called on his network to
defend Iraq and keep Isis away from Iran
by now he had unprecedented influence
and continued to command Shia militias
in Iraq directly even after they were
officially folded into a Rox military
when a civil war erupted in Yemen Iran
threw its support behind a rebel
now instead of being surrounded by
enemies Iran had them surrounded
sulemani empowered a vast array of
militias across the Middle East
many of them are excessively violent and
have killed thousands many are
designated terrorist organizations by
the US and EU and many are corrupt
Lebanese Hezbollah and the Iraqi Shia
militias for instance are the targets of
mass protests in those countries and
they're putting down the protests with
more violence but to Iran and its
supporters Salman is a hero he helped
build a web of militias that not only
keeps Iran's enemies in check but also
provides a pipeline for the Islamic
ideology that Iran wanted to see in the
far corners of the Middle East it's why
I Ron Supreme Leader immediately called
Seoul money a martyr and also declared
that his efforts and path will be
stopped after his killing so even though
its commander is gone the network
remains intact
[Music]